[Musica]
no
per chi ha più figli luca
i numeri non andiamo in giardino di abu
dhabi per evitare curri vediamo mi sento
stavo dormendo stavi dormendo per terra
morto sull'amaca sbrigati devo farti
vedere una cosa che mi sono appena
svegliato
c'è qualcosa in camera in camera c'è già
qualcuno in camera questa no nella
nostra camera sbrigati andiamo che la
porta era aperta aveva chiuso la porta a
chiave
sì c'era qualcuno dentro c'è qualcuno
adesso non lo so controlliamo
ma non mi sembra ci sia qualcuno qui
finito c'è qualcuno dovete il lupo a
tutto ciò è molto strano lupo ma che
stai dicendo
i ricordi le tracce dell'altra volta si
è un po lungo da spiegare comunque c'era
un lupo quanti non proprio un lupo ma un
cane lupo ma anche berlino fitto vero
berlino rivisto chiudo merli io che io
mi fa visto il mio berlino dove è andato
tentato il lupo a no dai
mi stai prendendo in giro un'altra volta
è uno scherzo vero non è uno scherzo
guarda che sono i periodi merlino no
sono i peli del lupo guardateli del lupo
guarda non sono i peli di merlino sono
buchi neri sono i mali del lupo ma si
sono i periti merlino sono altri qua mi
chiamo se riesco a trovare qualche
contraddizione di chi sono i veri di
merlino sono i periti marlino guarda
questo è un colore bianco e nero mentre
il marino è un po bianco un po giallo e
un po marroncino vedi che non è lo
stesso colore
a me sembrano i colori di merlino sono i
pali di marino sono i peli del lupo
marino dirglielo anche tu guarda
no non si mangiano dopo berlino non ti
mangiano sono le uniche prove che ho
quindi ipoteticamente parlando se ci
fosse stato un lupo va dove è finito non
lo so
forse merlino lo sa berlino dove è
andato il lupo
[Musica]
eppure il giardino berlino è uscito in
giardino il lupo limitrofe in giardino
petite l'ho detto berlina rosa merlino
rappresentato sta dicendo che il
giardino il giardino devo andare a
controllare in giardino prima che torni
dentro caso però non posso uscire
direttamente in giardino potrebbe essere
pericoloso idea
porterò il mio binocolo e controllerò
dalla terrazza se c'è qualcosa in
giardino non controlla qua alla finestra
ok se senti qualcosa
avvisami subito ottima idea si va beh
facciamo così vediamo se c'è qualcosa in
giardino
[Musica]
è già qualcosa
eccolo il lupo si stanno scontento
[Musica]
ma che sta facendo
si è nascosto
andiamo subito a prenderle a partire
vitale si no
che cos'è un provino cento qui mi
aspettavo stavo mangiando mangiando
mi sto mangiando davvero diceva che cosa
in mano lo sapevo di dei mento mangiare
non hai controllato pure dalla pietra se
il lupo in giardino di avevo letto di
controllarla il buco giardino ovvero
verranno fuori
sì l'ho visto con il binocolo davvero e
non stavi proprio portando basir mi sono
distratto un attimo nuovo per rendere il
solo io ora vado il giardino in mezzo
dove si è nascosto tu stai attento alla
finestra il tuo bisogno di aiuto essi
subito che sono più concentrati fuori
dalla finestra molto fuori dalla
finestra e se non lo faccio per te lo
[Musica]
guardo fuori dalla finestra non mangia
il gelato
guardo fuori dalla finestra ma all
mangia il gelato tutto guardando che i
ragazzi sono qua in giardino vediamo se
troviamo qualcosa di sospetto
per ora non vedo niente di gela ciao
berlino sta seguendo la terza del lupo
posta dove merlino aiutami a trovarlo
berlino un fiuto infallibile quindi con
berlino riusciremo sicuramente a trovare
il gruppo dove stai andando berlino
hai sentito qualcosa non so se marino
sta realmente seguendo qualche traccia
provo comunque a seguirlo tanto c'è
vitale che controlla avido mi ha detto
di stare attento
io devo stare attento pregiato che si
scioglie sentito qualcosa che proveniva
dalla giunta andiamo a controllare
io voglio solo parlare con il lupo e
dirgli che non voglio fargli del male e
sono sicura che lui non è cattivo forza
ma dopo quella chiamata è diventato
cattivo se lo facessi nuovamente parlare
al telefono forse questa è la soluzione
fermo fermo non avvicinarsi non
avvicinarti ok mi sembra molto
arrabbiato e mi fa scappare
[Musica]
ita sanità svegliati carlino cosa è
successo perché sono poi a letto ti ho
portato io qui mi hai portato qui
sì ero fuori in giardino cosa è successo
che strano non mi ricordo niente come
non ti ricordi niente va bene allora ti
porto a qualcosa da mangiare
così ti sentirai meglio è che ne dici ok
grazie arrivo subito aspettati che
strano io non mi ricordo niente e così è
successo in giardino
però mi fa male il braccio
[Musica]